the jurogan experience but pumas are you
know an established animal to to have
like some cryptozoological
creature like bigfoot that's undetected
but it's fun it's fun i want to believe
yeah but i don't really well that's like
in the ocean like they find some big
fish to you know or some big yeah well
like extra like some and you're like i
don't know dude we never knew it was
down there the compelling this time i
think
yeah that's how much that was jeremy
corbell was talking about the other day
that they um
you know it's hard to say like what kind
of information he's getting how accurate
it is but they're basically saying think
about the movie abyss where the aliens
lived under water it was like that's
probably what's going on yeah there's
some sort of
alien base
underwater or some meeting place or
that's where they hide that's where they
go to be undetected do you think you're
going to see it in your lifetime bigfoot
or aliens
like uh you know where it's like oh like
we have to like talk to them now we have
to interact with them there are there's
a video that is impossible to ignore
there's some things that are impossible
to ignore and then there's eyewitness
testimonies of people who are
rock-solid
totally dependable like fighter pilots
who have seen some things like the best
examples this guy commander david fravor
who was off the coast of san diego in
2004
and this is corroborated by multiple
points of data they
had this
this tracking system that tracks things
above earth's atmosphere and they found
this thing went from
above 60 000 feet above sea level to
50 feet above sea level in less than a
second they have no idea how it's doing
this
they have no idea there's no method of
propulsion that's visible they've
followed this thing they locked on to it
it blocked their radar it blocked their
tracking systems rather and then it
jetted off at an impossible rate of
speed and then the nimitz
relocated this thing at their cat point
the cat point is where the fighter
pilots when they're doing this test
they're doing this exercise they were
supposed to meet at this very specific
point and that's where this thing had
gone like this thing had read their
their manifest and knew like or read
their or their plans and knew where they
were going what's well that that is way
more compelling to me than bigfoot the
bigfoot thing is just fun but the alien
thing is fun and likely there's
something going on and so i go back and
forth sometimes i think it maybe it's
some sort of government drone that's
like so sophisticated and they're
that you know they it's totally top
secret and if we ever go to war with
china that's when they're going to break
it out and then sometimes i think
what they are is something that's
monitoring us and making sure we don't
blow ourselves up making sure that we
we make this journey from territorial
apes with thermonuclear weapons into
some sort of an advanced
intergalactic society and that there's a
very crucial moment where the instincts
of these tribal people which is all of
us all human beings these
tribal territorial people
where you have to keep them from
sabotaging any possible future
progress
by blowing themselves up by killing each
other by what if we talk to them and
then
they and then when you say that they go
yeah that was it
it's that easy like not that easy but
like you just go is that it there you go
yeah that's about it you're trying to
keep you guys involved in yourselves
this is like but maybe that's like the
natural thing that you see
like when civilizations advance like
there's a very precarious moment where
like they have the capability to blow
themselves up but the reason and the
logic to not do it but they also have
these instincts to control resources and
take over territories they still have
those instincts but they have to bypass
that they have to figure out how to and
so that's when aliens start circling and
and
just keeping an eye on us yeah this is
that that's the that's what you would
hope right instead of like them
attacking us yes because then so i think
if they were going to attack us they
would have already done it like
like
if they really could do all those things
they could probably take out our power
grid pretty easy apparently they're they
the stories are that they're able to
shut down nuclear launches and nuclear
facilities and that they do that and
they they hover over military bases and
that they'll just shut everything down
just to let you know hey [ __ ]
you know i just flipped that switch so
yeah don't get too [ __ ] squirrely
that's so crazy
you